Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sama Sambuddhassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sama Sambuddhassa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sammasambuddhassam Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So, I thought this evening just to continue with the problems that we come across in our meditation.
E poi domani vorrei che ascoltassi la prima parola, la parola che Mahasi lui stesso ha dato sulla sua tecnica di meditazione.
E domani mi piacerebbe se voi ascoltaste il primo discorso in assoluto che Masi fece riguardo la sua pratica meditativa.
Poi domani parleremo un po' dell'aspetto un po' più positivo, bello, luminoso della meditazione.
Quello che chiamiamo i fattori dell'enlightenment.
ciò che vengono denominati fattori di illuminazione.
Ieri abbiamo appena accennato al problema dell'irrequietezza, quindi oggi vorrei approfondire un pochino questa problematica.
Quindi abbiamo detto che le modalità in cui noi esperiamo l'energia all'interno del nostro corpo può essere o con un movimento
verso l'interno, che si manifesta con uno stato di letargia, oppure un movimento verso l'esterno che si manifesta con uno stato di irrequietezza.
E questa irrequietezza può essere sia nella mente che nel corpo.
Se è irrequietezza si può manifestare o a livello della mente o a livello del corpo.
O entrambi.
E...
Possiamo dire che è parte della modalità con cui noi ci relazioniamo con situazioni che sono dolorose o comunque poco confortevoli.
Invece di confrontarci con situazioni difficili, solitamente tentiamo di allontanarci da queste situazioni.
Di darcela a gambe elevate.
Supponiamo di considerare, ad esempio, il problema della solitudine.
L'amore è quella sensazione di essere isolato, di essere non amato, di essere non voluto.
E quindi spesso cosa facciamo?
Telefoniamo a un amico e gli diciamo che ci sentiamo soli.
Telefoniamo a un amico
L'amico ci dice, oh ma facciamo così, andiamo al cinema assieme.
Ma in questo modo, però, non stiamo indagando questa sensazione di solitudine, troviamo una sorta di escamotage, cioè di facile modalità per non confrontarci con la situazione.
La parola per la solitudine è solitudine.
solitudine in italiano stare attenti non è stare da soli ma sentirsi soli feeling lonely being alone both meanings both meanings solitudine negativa negative solitudine
Questa sensazione di essere da soli, di non essere desiderati, permane comunque nel sistema.
Quando inizia a manifestarsi questa situazione emotiva di solitudine spesso si manifesta non direttamente sotto quella forma ma come una sorta di irrequietezza.
C'è stato una meditante che un tempo mi è venuta a parlare perché si sentiva così sola al punto di contemplare il suicidio.
Quindi ho spiegato a lei questa maniera di affrontarlo, di farlo manifestare, di sedersi tranquillamente con lui, e di solo sentirlo, di sperimentarlo e di dargli tempo per svegliarsi.
Quindi io l'ho istruita su come relazionarsi con questa situazione, semplicemente sedendosi con questa emozione, percependola nel corpo, dando il tempo di che si manifestasse e che poco alla volta si esaurisse.
E poi le ho chiesto cosa pensi che capita quando la solitudine giunge al suo termine.
She said despair.
E le ha detto arriva la disperazione.
I said no, no, no.
E io le ho detto no, no.
Quando tutto questo complesso di sensazioni, emozioni, di...
essere isolati, non desiderati, non amati, finalmente hanno la possibilità di manifestarsi, ciò che si esperisce al termine di questo processo è uno stato di solitudine, ma non di sentirsi soli.
Capite in italiano la differenza dei due termini?
Sì?
No.
In inglese solitude significa che sei perfettamente contento di essere on your own.
Allora, in inglese il termine solitudine sta a indicare un perfetto appagamento nell'essere da soli.
Ora, nell'insegnamento del Buddha il ricercare questo stato di solitudine è parte integrante dell'insegnamento.
Viveka è questo termine che indica questo aspetto che abbiamo appena esplorato e che andrebbe perseguito.
Diceva che noi dovremmo muoverci, vagare da soli nel mondo come un rinoceronte.
Perché il rinoceronte di solito se ne sta per i fatti suoi, non va in giro in gruppo.
E ovviamente è un animale molto forte.
E quindi quando siamo contenti di noi stessi, c'è grande forza in questo.
Quindi quando c'è questo stato di, definiamola così in italiano, di contentezza in noi stessi, c'è una grossa forza.
Ad esempio, spesso noi possiamo...
fingere di essere d'accordo con una persona anche se in realtà non siamo per niente d'accordo con quella persona perché c'è una paura che se manifestiamo questo disaccordo rimarremo da soli.
Allora questo senso di solitudine può avere effetti
nella nostra vita di cui spesso noi non siamo consapevoli quella negativa sì la stessa cosa per quelle emozioni sensazioni che ci fanno sentire molto agitati come l'ansia ora
Udaccia e cucuccia sono i due termini palio-originari che vengono utilizzati dal Buddha in questa enumerazione di questi impedimenti.
E già il termine Udaccia e cucuccia dà un senso di irrequietezza, no?
This udacia is the restlessness that we feel through guilt, shame and, yes, guilt and shame.
Udacia è quel senso di irrequietezza che noi percepiamo attraverso il senso di colpa e la vergogna.
Sometimes you might catch yourself
Ad esempio si può sperimentare questo senso di colpa, di paura, quando incontriamo un poliziotto.
Anche io come monaco.
Ora, queste figure autoritarie spesso possono far sorgere questi stati emotivi di cui di solito non siamo consapevoli.
Da quei tre atteggiamenti, disposizioni fondamentali,
Nasce un secondo livello di disposizioni che possiamo individuare con il senso di colpa, la vergogna e il rimorso.
I primi tre livelli sono greed, attaccamento, hatred, odio e delusion, illusione.
Ora, da questo stato illusorio in cui noi vogliamo che il mondo ci dia felicità, noi sviluppiamo quelle due modalità fondamentali che sono di
accumulazione e accumuliamo perché più abbiamo più ci sentiamo sicuri
Ricordate che sappiamo che viviamo in un mondo molto insicuro.
Ora ricordiamoci che al nostro interno noi sappiamo benissimo di vivere in un mondo estremamente insicuro.
Domani potremmo risvegliarci molto malati o morti, chi lo sa.
Quindi sappiamo, qualcosa in noi lo sa, quindi qualsiasi cosa che ci renda sicuri ci raccogliamo di più.
Allora, una parte di noi lo sa benissimo questo, e qualsiasi cosa che ci dia un senso di maggiore sicurezza noi tendiamo a volerlo accumulare, a volerne di più.
Ci sentiamo molto più sicuri con un milione di euro che soltanto con cento euro.
Ora, c'è parte di questo processo di senso di accumulare che potremmo quasi definirlo, anche se il termine è un po' curioso, morale.
Anche nella vita monastica il Buddha dice che abbiamo quattro requisiti.
Cibo, vestiti, un rifugio, un luogo dove essere riparati e le medicine.
Dice ovviamente che dobbiamo fare la cosa più semplice delle cose.
Ovviamente poi esplica che dovremmo accontentarci delle cose più semplici possibili.
Dovremmo essere felici di ciò che ci viene offerto nella ciotola per le offerte e per quanto riguarda il cibo.
Dovremmo anche essere felici con dei vestiti fatti da stracci.
Dovremmo essere felici anche vivendo sotto un albero, questo dipende dal tempo che c'è ovviamente.
E per quanto riguarda l'aspetto delle medicine dovremmo essere felici di poter utilizzare dell'urina fermentata di vacca.
Io non l'ho mai provata.
Quindi possiamo affermare che c'è una sorta di appunto voler raccogliere
come dire, beni materiali, amici, famiglia, che è parte integrale del costituente di essere un essere umano.
Però sappiamo anche che la cupidigia, l'accumulare non ha confini.
in ultima analisi ci piacerebbe poter possedere l'universo e poterlo controllare cioè avere il controllo c'è un punto in cui la nostra modalità acquisitiva di appropriazione inizia a prendere agli altri
E a questo punto noi iniziamo a entrare in una relazione etica non corretta con le altre persone e con il mondo.
E questo è il punto in cui noi iniziamo a percepire questo senso di colpa.
Ora questo senso di colpa è semplicemente la paura delle conseguenze possibili.
Così come noi ci siamo appropriati indebitamente di un qualcosa che non era nostro sappiamo benissimo che la stessa cosa potrebbe accadere a noi.
E quindi noi iniziamo a entrare, a essere in un mondo in cui vediamo nemici.
E questo ci rende molto inquieti.
Quindi questa paura delle conseguenze è parte della lezione, ovviamente, della legge del karma.
Questo fa parte degli insegnamenti che riguardano la legge del karma.
Quindi se durante le nostre pratiche meditative sorgono questi
emozioni di sensi di colpa sia riguardanti il fatto di esserci appropriati indebitamente di un qualcosa che non era nostro sia per aver provocato sofferenza a qualcun altro è necessario lasciare che queste situazioni interiori emotive si possano manifestare
possono anche essere viste come le conseguenze karmiche di queste azioni immorali che noi abbiamo compiuto queste emozioni che noi percepiamo e ricordiamoci
Non possiamo farci assolutamente nulla.
Ora, se sorge un senso di colpa riguardo alla maniera in cui abbiamo trattato qualcun altro, ovviamente possiamo poi scusarci con quella persona.
e in un certo senso questo ammorbidirà questo senso di colpa però spesso c'è molto di questo senso di colpa che risale a eventi che noi abbiamo completamente dimenticato
Ricordiamoci che un senso di colpa molto forte si può manifestare in uno stato paranoico.
Quando dico paranoia non parlo di malattia mentale.
In questo caso non stiamo parlando di una malattia mentale.
Ma semplicemente iniziare ad avere quella sensazione che è come avere tutti contro mentre in realtà non è così.
quindi durante la pratica meditativa se sorge questo stato di senso di colpa è un'occasione che abbiamo per poterla percepire
sentire lasciare che si manifesti perché vedete solitamente quando queste cose emergono solitamente noi ci spaventiamo ma in un certo senso è necessario che noi ci rilassiamo sapendo che questo senso di colpa non ci ucciderà e molto velocemente
E molto lentamente, semplicemente, scomparirà.
Più siamo in grado di aprirci a queste situazioni interiori e accoglierle, sopportarle con pazienza, più velocemente si sciolgono, se ne vanno.
Il Buddha affermava che era importante nella vita spirituale perché questo senso di colpa diventa, si trasforma in una sorta di guardiano di sentinella per il nostro comportamento futuro.
perché ogni volta che pensi che farai qualcosa di immorale ricorda che non vuole quella terribile colpa infatti dice che la colpa e la colpa sono i guardiani della società
Infatti il Buddha afferma che il senso di colpa e il senso di vergogna sono le sentine dei guardiani della società.
Se nell'ambito della società le persone perdessero questo senso di colpa o di vergogna
la comunità, la società diventerebbe un luogo senza legge.
Questo lo possiamo vedere, io sto pensando in questo momento all'Inghilterra, in alcune delle nostre città, in cui la popolazione giovane compie atti terribili, ma non percepisce assolutamente nessun senso né di vergogna né di colpa rispetto a queste azioni.
Solo alcuni.
Quindi ora, con la vergogna esce la vergogna.
Allora, con il senso di colpa sorge anche questo senso di vergogna, definiamolo così.
Allora, è quello stato emotivo che noi esperiamo
quando noi tradiamo noi stessi si direbbe in italiano quando ad esempio noi abbiamo un ideale di noi stessi come se fossimo una brava persona e poi facciamo qualcosa e tutti conoscono oh, non sei così buono
E poi noi facciamo qualcosa ed è come se tutti iniziassero a dirci ma tu non sei poi così tanto bravo.
E allora sentiamo questo senso di vergogna e di imbarazzo.
E' una cosa divertente ma puoi sentire più imbarazzo e scemo con un semplice gaffo sociale che puoi con un vero e vero atto immorale.
Ed è buffo pensare come ci si può sentire più imbarazzati con una semplice gaffe dal punto di vista sociale, che con un reale atto immorale.
Gaffe, la stessa parola?
Sì.
c'è stata una meravigliosa occasione per questa cosa alla corte della regina Elisabetta I in Inghilterra
Walter Raleigh, che probabilmente era un poeta che, se ci ricordiamo bene, ha fondato la colonia della Virginia negli Stati Uniti, e ovviamente era in relazione piuttosto stretta con la regina.
E mentre, una volta nel full court, ha fartato.
e una volta nel bel mezzo della corte si può dire lasciò uscire dei gas intestinali un bel scoriggio scoriggione he stayed away from court for one year
Dopo questo accadimento non si fece più vedere la corte per un anno intero.
Quando ritornò la regina lo salutò.
Bentornato Sir Walter.
Noi ci siamo dimenticati della scorreggia.
Ora, questo...
Ora, qui c'è qualcosa che dobbiamo capire più chiaramente, che l'emozione è causata dall'attitudine, non dall'azione.
l'emozione è causata direttamente dall'atteggiamento che c'è non dall'azione questo è un fatto che va capito in maniera molto molto chiara la vergogna che provava Sir Walter
Era causata dalla sua comprensione, dal suo atteggiamento rispetto a ciò che aveva fatto.
Qualcun altro sarebbe potuto stare lontano dalla corte solo per un giorno.
ora quando sorgono queste emozioni questi stati di senso di colpa e vergogna allora l'atteggiamento è esattamente lo stesso che abbiamo con tutte le altre cose che possono sorgere al nostro interno durante la pratica
Lasciamo andare il pensiero ed è come se ci lasciassimo affondare, penetrare dentro la sensazione.
La sentiamo, lasciamo che si manifesti pienamente.
E questo è lo stesso per la terza qualità del rimorso.
Questo vale anche per il terzo aspetto che è il rimorso.
Il rimorso è il processo di guarigione rispetto alla vergogna e allo senso di colpa.
Il rimorso può essere di varie intensità, possiamo ritrovarci a piangere ad esempio.
Quando il piangere sorge dal rimorso si permette al pianto di piangere.
si permette a questa emozione molto forte di esprimersi.
La stessa cosa con la tristezza.
Se un'emozione è così forte da volersi esprimere attraverso il pianto allora si permette che questo sia.
Ora, se questo ci dovesse capitare qui nel ritiro e dovessimo riscoprirci imbarazzati da questa cosa, allora ci troviamo un posticino tranquillo.
Sì.
Volevo chiedere...
dunque quando il senso di colpa e la vergogna sono dati da un fatto magari del passato e quindi si riesce a riconoscere queste sensazioni che tornano si riescono magari a osservare quando invece sono dati da un condizionamento cioè magari in famiglia una persona che non avrebbe nulla di cui vergognarsi e sentirsi in colpa però per tanti anni si prova questa cosa poi arrivano queste sensazioni che non si riescono a
Supponiamo che questo senso di vergogna e di vergogna
non è veramente trascinabile in un'azione singola, ma forse è il prodotto di un ambiente, una famiglia, un'educazione, eccetera.
Allora è proprio questo che sto tentando di spiegare che spesso
ciò che noi proviamo nel presente, ha perso oramai il suo collegamento con il passato, in inglese chiamano leftovers, che non so in italiano come si dica, sono degli avanzi, ma che non riusciamo a far risalire a qualcosa di specifico.
Questo è proprio il motivo per cui si lascia perdere qualsiasi tipo di processo all'indietro di andare a ricercare
Perché non ha nulla a che fare con l'emozione che si sta provando qui, in questo momento, ora.
Il Buddha dà un'immagine molto forte per questa cosa.
Allora, supponiamo che durante una battaglia una persona venga colpita da una freccia.
E i suoi amici lo soccorrono per estrarne la freccia e per medicarlo.
E lui dice, no, no, non toglietela, io prima voglio sapere chi me l'ha scagliata, perché stanno combattendo contro noi.
Prima di sapere tutte queste robe, questo poveretto muore, no?
Quanto invece riguarda questo processo di guarigione è proprio un permettere al cuore nella sua emotività più cruda di esprimersi.
Oh mio Dio, c'è molto da dire.
Passiamo al problema del dubbio.
Nella vita del Buddha c'è questo momento di tremendo dubbio.
Nella vita del Buddha giunge poi un momento in cui c'è un dubbio terribile.
Dopo aver seguito tutto il training possibile e non aver trovato ancora la risposta, decide con molta determinazione di sedersi sotto quell'albero e di o trovare la soluzione per porre fine alla sofferenza o morire.
E come si dice in quei tempi, Mara è apparita.
e così come veniva posto nel linguaggio di quel tempo ecco che salta fuori Mara e Mara gli dice ma chi ti credi di essere per poterti permettere di stare sostituto sotto quell'albero a ricercare la fine della sofferenza?
questo mondo appartiene a me Mara riguarda i piaceri le gioie del mondo tutte queste cose ma il Buddha era forte grazie alle sue perfezioni
Ma il Buddha era piuttosto forte grazie alle sue perfezioni.
Specialmente viene affermato quella che riguardava la generosità.
E
Qualsiasi tipo di arma gli venisse gettata contro si trasformava in fiori.
E profumi.
Fiori e profumi.
Che vuol dire?
vuol dire che se noi ce ne stiamo seduti qua con tutti questi stati negativi infine noi vedremo la loro trasformazione vediamo che si trasforma nel loro posto allora tutto l'egoismo si trasforma in generosità tutto l'odio in amore
Tutta la crudeltà in compassione.
Tutta la solitudine negativa in solitudine positiva.
Tutto si trasformerà nel suo opposto.
questa cosa è enunciata nel secondo del nobile Ottubice Sentiero sotto la denominazione in italiano come si può esprimere?
la retta atteggiamento a volte è tradotto come retto pensiero ma non è proprio corretto perché l'esempio che dal Buddha è quello che vi ho appena riferito
Love to hate, hate to love.
Quindi, amore in odio, ah no, odio in amore.
Allora il dubbio sorge dalla paura.
Viene da quel luogo, da quella posizione di non so, non conosco, non oso.
Voglio andare in un bosco, in una selva oscura, ma non so cosa c'è lì dentro e non ci vado.
Non oso andarci.
Ora, per quanto riguarda la pratica meditativa, ciò che ci dà il coraggio
coraggio è il fatto che noi stiamo utilizzando una tradizione sapienziale molto antica se fosse solo il Buddha potremmo dire beh oddio non c'è mica tanto da filarsi ma siccome è una tradizione di 2500 anni
bene questa roba allora c'è questa disponibilità a prendere questo medicamento questa medicina ora quando sorge il dubbio in ambito di questo campo religioso si può presentare sotto tre forme principali dubbio nel Buddha negli insegnamenti nella tradizione
Dubbi riguardo all'insegnante?
No, perché non voglio dire che no.
E naturalmente soprattutto dubbi in se stessi.
E noi abbiamo seri dubbi sul fatto di poterci relazionare con queste emozioni.
Magari impazziremo, chi lo sa.
Tutti riescono a sedersi, io no.
Sono speciale così.
Io sono speciale.
Allora, quando sorgono questi dubbi, non ascoltate il linguaggio.
Ricordiamoci, la mente è una bugiarda.
Quindi andate nei sentimenti di dubbio, le paure.
E allora proprio immergiamoci nelle sensazioni del dubbio, nelle paure.
Quando iniziano a perdere potenza, allora riconvinciamo noi stessi della validità di questo percorso.
Quindi spesso troviamo, specialmente quelli di noi che sono nuovi a questo tipo di meditazione, che è molto potente.
Specialmente le persone che sono nuove in questo tipo di meditazione possono scoprire che è piuttosto potente.
Specialmente se sei il tipo di persona che in realtà non sente molto le sue emozioni, ma rimane molto potente.
specialmente se sei quella sorta di persona che non sente molto le emozioni, ma rimane più di testa.
Molto spesso persone di questo tipo quando entrano in contatto con questo mondo emotivo hanno una situazione di shock, di orrore.
Sicuramente è capitato a me.
Allora, quando si entra finalmente in contatto con questa vita emotiva, queste turbulenze interiori, è necessario lasciare che si possa manifestare, esprimere.
e se sentiamo che è un po' troppo potente in quel momento possiamo delicatamente spostare un pochino la nostra presenza
Si può andare a fare una passeggiata, in casi come questo si può addirittura leggere un libro.
ma qualsiasi cosa si faccia non scappiamo via e ricordatevi che potete venire a parlarne con me di questa cosa allora non pensate che
Sprecate il mio tempo o che io non ne sia interessato a questa cosa.
Questo è il mio lavoro.
E quello che troverete, specialmente quelli di voi che sono nuovi, è che se potete passare da una crisi, poi le altre non sono un problema.
Quello che si scopre, specialmente se siamo nuovi a questa pratica, è che se si riesce ad attraversare una crisi, quelle successive non sono più un problema.
È riuscire a superare il primo ostacolo.
Il primo ostacolo.
anche nel processo di risveglio spirituale sorgono emozioni che però hanno la caratteristica di essere un po' emozioni spirituali
Ad esempio, possiamo sentirci ansiosi, insicuri riguardo al nostro lavoro.
Allora, quando iniziamo a investigare quest'area del sé, allora sorge questa domanda, beh, ma io chi sono?
spesso sorge una grande paura perché il sé ha un'enorme paura di perdere se stesso fino ad ora il sé ha creduto di essere un essere umano con corpo, delle emozioni, pensieri
Ma improvvisamente tutte queste cose diventano degli oggetti.
E questo può essere esperito dal meditante come qualcosa di piuttosto spaventevole, spaventoso.
Quindi questo tipo di esperienza di emozione è un'emozione spirituale.
Perché si sta scoprendo che si è realmente.
Allora è necessario andarsene da casa per scoprire la propria vera casa.
nel misticismo cristiano vengono utilizzati questi due termini fascinans et tremens fascinating and yet fearful è un qualcosa di
affascinante cioè una affascinazione il traduzione del latino è affascinante e treme bondo cioè affascina interessa ma allo stesso tempo incuta timore si è curiosi si vuole conoscere ma allo stesso tempo si ha paura questi due sono spesso nella nostra pratica
Spesso ritroviamo questi due elementi nella nostra pratica.
Penso sia sufficiente, almeno per me.
Allora lasciatemi incoraggiarvi perché dopo due giorni stiamo entrando proprio nel ritiro sentendoci un po' più a nostro agio.
Quindi ciò che si può fare è di cercare di centrarsi sempre di più sul proprio sé.
Quindi cerchiamo di non comunicare con altre persone anche semplicemente guardandole, cerchiamo di chiudere un po' il mondo intorno a noi.
in questo modo diventa più chiaro il modo in cui la mente si comporta noi cerchiamo di ridurre
Se ci sono delle domande rispetto a questo discorso o domande d'armi che comunque potete sempre scriverle e metterle in questo cestino che c'è qua.
Sediamoci in maniera tranquilla per un secondo.
Spero che le mie parole siano state di una qualche utilità per voi e sinceramente mi auguro che voi siate liberati prima piuttosto che poi.